cette vidéo est sponsorisée par aup
saviez-vous que la perception du goût
est en réalité dictée par l'odorat et
bien aup ça ressemble à une gourde mais
c'est bien plus que ça dans aup vous
pouvez activer un pod aromatisé qui va
venir jouer avec vos sens ainsi en
buvant avec une gourde de aup vous aurez
la sensation de boire une délicieuse
boisson sucrée alors qu'en réalité vous
n'avalez que de l'eau ça s'appelle la
rétroolfaction et comme vous buvez de
l'eau c'est absolument zéro calories
waouh ça veut dire que si je bois de la
badoie et qu'en même temps vous me pétez
au visage je vais avoir la sensation de
de boire de la badoie au proute
euh est-ce qu'on peut changer d'acteur
s'il vous plaît ça marche très
simplement remplissz votre gourde et
activez votre pod parmi le large
éventail de goûts différents proposé par
herup orange chocolat Virgin Morito ba
sauvage frais ver veine citronné melon
miel vinaigre blanc et je attendez
excusez-moi non ça c'est le pit pour les
chiottes et si je peux rien sentir parce
que je suis absolument tout le temps
enrumé et bien vous pouvez toujours
attirer l'attention de vos amis grâce à
cette gourde à la forme si particulière
hey c'est quoi cette gourde à la forme
si particulière ça c'est de la
réroolfaction tiens-moi ça metstoi à
genou je vais chercher de la
[Musique]
badoie bénéficier de 10 à 40 % de
réduction jusqu'au 26 décembre inclus en
fonction du panier d'achat l'offre est
appliquée directement avec le lien et si
vous arrivez trop tard utilisez le code
JDG pour avoir 15 % de réduction sur les
gourdes airup jusqu'au 24 janvier
joyeux
[Musique]
Noël les meilleures Blex tu nous en
une non et c'est pas fini ouvre le
suivant chapeau anti extraterrestre
vas-y
metsle et voilà tu vois des
extraterrestres non
W vas-y ouvre le
[Musique]
suivant
W mais c'est le exactement c'est la
version miniature du sapin de la place
vom en 2014 oh mais trop bien c'est la
version collector avec le joyeux en
dessous allez vas-y ouvre ton cadeau
W une cassette VHS de Noël de Leclerc de
1996 pour commander des jouets qui
existent
plus un paquet de sauciss j'ai entamé ah
c'est exactement ce que je voulais on la
[Musique]
regarde 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une tradition bien particulière qu'on a
jamais abordé sur cette chaîne même pas
un petit peu c'est les VHS de Noël un
petit retour dans le passé dans les
années 90 sans internet il y avait pas
50 moyens de savoir quel jouet acheter
il y avait évidemment les pubs à la télé
hein ça semblait le plus évident dès
qu'on a du mois de décembre c'était pas
difficile à voir même sans calendrier
puisque toutes les coupures pub
commençaient à être envahies de pub de
jouet de poupée de jeux vidéo de jeux de
société et cetera 08 36 65 65 65 et
c'est toujours le cas he finalement il y
avait les catalogues c'était le feu que
ce soit la redoute ou les trucs de pub
que tu recevais dans les boîtes aux
lettres quand j'étais petit j'aimais
trop parcourir les catalogues de jouets
et regarder tous ces trucs que j'aurais
jamais et une troisième technique
beaucoup moins connue c'était les VHS de
Noël en gros des VHS mises à disposition
gratuitement dans les magasins comme le
CLER ouochamp alors personnellement j'ai
pas connu ça puisque quand j'ai eu mon
premier magnétoscope et bien j'étais
déjà adolescent mais comme c'est la
période de Noël et bien c'est un peu
l'occasion de se replonger dedans les
VHS de Noël c'est toujours un petit peu
le même format l'idée vous vous en
doutez c'est juste de vendre des jouets
aux enfants mais attention il faut pas
que ça ressemble à une pub déguisée de 1
heure même si dans l'absolu c'est
exactement ce que c'est il faut donc
quand même qu'il y a un petit scénario
cette première VHS est donc la VHS de
Noël 1996 des magasins Leclerc elle
commence donc par le Père Noël qui
reçoit un coup de fil ses jouets ont
disparu pas possible maises jouets tous
les originaux mais oh mes chinois où
sont mes
chinois lutin je veux dire et le grand
classique dans le scénario de ces
cassettes c'est d'appeler les clients
enfin je veux dire les les enfants à
l'aide c'est donc ce qu'il fait mais ça
ne suffira pas il va avoir besoin de
quelquun d'autre pour l'aider à
retrouver les originaux de ses jouets
volés par les gros Pau encore un coup
des gros Pau exactement c'est les
méchants bien joué waouh je vais appeler
un ami à
moi bonjour mon ami sangoan je ne te
dérange pas trop ah W oh waouh
euh alors je je suis content mais mais
surpris euh content mais content
mais plus surpris que content et oui
effectivement c'était Abé prod qui
produisait les cassettes de Noël de
Leclerc de 96 à
ce qui explique la présence de Gohan ne
t'en fais pas je vais demander à son
Goku de m'aider à localiser ses jouets
je te rappelle dans un instant je crois
qu'il parle très vite comme ça parce
qu'il fallait que ça colle sur la
lipsink c'est d'ailleurs pour la même
raison que certaines scènes de ces VHS
de Noël sont tourné dans des décors
àprod par exemple ça et bien si on
compare c'est exactement les mêmes
décors que la série extra zigda dont on
a déjà parlé et ça vous voyez c'est moi
qui l'ai trouvé
ouais ah c'est vraiment de l'espace Mo
utilisé pour rien dans mon cerveau hein
super je savais pas que tu étais ami
avec Son Gohan tu ne serais pas copain
avec ai par
hasard mais es complètement code ou quoi
mais c'est le Moon c'est un dessin animé
espèce de débile il y a pas que Gohan il
y a aussi Polux du manage en chanté ou
d'autres personnages que j'ai
complètement oublié nouvelle et oui s
Goan m'a tout expliqué sang gookan sang
gokanan on est en 1996 ça fait 5
ans qu'ils diffusent des BZ ils en ont
vraiment rien à branler bref le principe
c'est un peu toujours pareil le Père
Noël a besoin d'aide comme j'ai dit il
lui faut des enfants et les enfants sont
envoyés chercher les jouets pour une
raison à la Conde dans différents mondes
je vous reçois très bien je vais
téléporter vos deux jeunes compagnons oh
comme ils sont mignons ah ouais mais
même des lois ils en ont rien à branler
en fait monsieur vous savez je pense
qu'il y a des lois sur le travail des
enfants non bah sur le travail des
enfants peut-être mais sur le travail
des bébés alors bon les enfants vont
jouer avec tout ce qu'ils vont croiser
évidemment en plus comme c'est
littéralement des bébés ils ne savent
pas ce qu'ils font réellement donc ben
du coup ils jouent réellement avec les
jouets et à chaque nouveau jouet Victor
l'écran d'ordinateur du Père Noël va
commenter les jouets avec une bonne
grosse
voix baby ttine il est très coquin ce
bébé le choix niveau marketing est
bizarre et pour revenir au Père Noël
dans cette vidéo c'est trop bizarre
parce qu'en fait il prend pas une voix
de Père Noël cliché comme comme on a
l'habitude d'entendre en mode oh les
enfants je suis le père Noël non non
c'est juste la voix normale de l'acteur
Père Noël est-ce que vous avez bien reçu
les données c'est super les enfants ça
marche à merveille oui c'est bien les
enfants lecl vous avez comme ça
donc après le premier monde pour les
bébés l'ordinateur les téléporte vers le
monde des jouets
suivants Père Noël Victor Kevin et
Morgan se sont pas rematérialisé
affirmatif ils ont assez travaillé ENF
travailler travailler il veut dire que
ch d'avoir envoyer
[Musique]
l'explication mais pas d'inquiétude ok
on a légalement pas le droit de retenir
de force des bébés pour les forcer à
travailler mais on peut quand même en
engager d'autres et faire tourner
l'équipe c'est donc deux nouveaux
enfants qui arrivent au passage on est
en 1996 on sent bien qu'on est vraiment
dans le pic de l' de Power Rangers vu l'
tenu oh c'est super chouette ici on va
bien
s'amuser alors je sais que c'est pas
volontaire mais on dirait vraiment
qu'elle se fout de leur gueule les
enfants vont donc enchaîner les planètes
après le segment pour bébés c'est le
segment avec les bébés qui pleur qui
chie qui pisse qui rotte et qui parfois
font tout en même temps après ça c'est
la caverne bois avec ses jouets
d'apprentissage on peut tout laver table
à repasser fer étendage et machine à
laver super c'est la vie comme les
grands ouais super waouh regardez c'est
tellement réaliste que les garçons
refusent même de jouer au tâaches
ménagère et ça aussi Chloé c'est la vie
comme les grands bref ensuite on a la
caverne rose pour les jouets Barbie avec
toujours les garçons qui lèvent les yeux
au ciel et font des réflexions toutes
les 2 minutes pour dire à quel point
c'est nul les beau cheveux au lieu de te
moquer un truc qui d'ailleurs sera
présent sur absolument toutes les VHS
puis ensuite c'est la caverne urbaine
c'est génial regarde qu niveaux pour
faire réparer garer et laver sa voiture
d'ailleurs qui a décrété cette
fascination des garçons pour les
voitures on était censé aimer quoi avant
que les voit soit inventé wou des roues
trop bien moi moi je trouve qu'il manque
quelque chose quand même chaque caverne
étant régulièrement interrompu par
l'arrivée et l'intervention des deux
gros mais qui se font toujours péter la
[Musique]
gueule ils sont
gros du coup ils sont bêtes
et hein et tout ça va évoluer sur fond
d'une petite amourette toute mimi qui se
développe entre Christophe et Zoé alors
bon d'abord il sequine un peu et puis
après il est jaloux et puis après elle
elle écre elle grave un collier avec un
petit cœur sur un jouet alors là mon
viux j'aurais préféré que tu trouves ça
super et que tu me fabriques un collier
à moi pour mon Noël
non non non fu fu maisaintenant sors
sors lâche l'affaire c'est mort bon
alors évidemment on va pas se taper tous
les passages avec les jouets ditvous
juste qu'à la fin le Père Noël récupère
tous ses jouets les gros POS sont
emprisonnés quant à la Mourette de la
remets ton bras où il
était
[Musique]
allez qui
êtes-vous e c'est Noël pour tout le
monde ça c'était donc la cassette de
1996 mais c'est pas la plus aboutie hein
je pense que la formule a vraiment
trouvé son pque avec l'année
suivante c'est bizarre de dire ça pour
un truc aussi con mais soit de la même
façon qu'avant on commence donc dans
l'atelier du Père Noël Père Noël
accompagné d'une petite fée de ah non
pardon c'est une femme à minijupe le
Père Noël recherche alors ses jumelles
[Rires]
pour ne fais pas ça oui ça ne fais pas
ça ah oui pour rappel c'était la fin des
années 90 à ce moment-là donc mettez des
effets sonores cyber futuristes un petit
peu partout parce que c'est le futur et
l'an 2000 ou le futur bref comme pour la
vidéo d'avant le scénario n'est
évidemment là que pour servir d'excuse à
vendre des jouets discrètement c'est une
création exceptionnelle enfin
discrètement je suis pas sûr que ce bébé
enfermé derrière des barreaux avec un
gros logo Lecler ça soit très discret
mais au moins ils essayent donc c'est
exactement le même schéma que la vidéo
précédente on commence d'abord par les
jouets de type
bébé tu dans son souffle wouh c'est
incroyable ce bébé est tellement
réaliste qu'il a attrapé une broncholite
regarde j'ai même prévu les couroi pour
la sécurité oui Père Noël mais dites-moi
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a une lunette de
sniper qui vise mon bébé et ça c'est
bébé guerre au Proche Orient pirouette
allez vite cache-toi ah j'aime pas le
bonheur ah ça c'est quelqu'un qui passe
trop de temps sur Twitter donc on
apprend que ce Ganondorf e plus là
s'appelle en réalité Nabor qu' complotte
pour faire en sorte que les enfants
n'aient pas de cadeau à Noël on apprend
aussi également que les pierres
précieuses pour commencer la
distribution elles sont dans les jouets
to le Père Noël trafique des pierres
précieuses et qu'il les cache dans des
jouets mais je vais faire comme si je
n'avais rien entendu les pierres
précieuses laissz la je vais aller les
chercher où est-ce que vous les avez
caché non non non non pouette tu en sais
déjà trop j'ai rien entendu j'ai rien
entendu Père Noël s'il vous plaît me
tuez pas Nabord donc utilise ces
pouvoirs magiqu de méchant pour faire
disparaître le Père Noël tandis que
pirouette ça fait prend la fuite
l'histoire bascule alors dans notre
monde à nous où on retrouve ensuite un
groupe de CIN enfants abandonné devant
la télé par leurs parents visiblement
pas là je t'ai déjà dit d'arrêter de me
parler comme ça mais c'est pas possible
tu as vraiment rien dans le CR c'est
incroyable déjà si tu arrêtais de
picoler mais non tu as toujours une
excuse ah ouais ça les excuses tu en
connais quelque chose hein ils sont
sûrement en train de préparer les
cadeaux le Père Noël depuis sa prison
n'a cependant pas perdu tous ses
pouvoirs et réussi malgré tout à passer
un appel à l'aide aux enfants mais
l'appel se fait intercepté et Nabor fait
également disparaître les enfants pour
les envoyer dans les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
catacombes j'ai
peur il ne faut pas avoir peur tant
qu'on reste tous ensemble il ne faut pas
avoir peur qui sais qu' va passer ses 15
prochaines années en thérapie qui
sais je t'avais dit que c'était comme ça
les enfants ont
disparu donc les enfants arrivent dans
la caverne sousterre mais heureusement
la fée pirouette les retrouve aussi la
lire VO la lumière ok très bien Lili
rends-moi ce ver de rouge tu as assez bu
pour aujourd'hui non malheureusement
j'ai perdu presque tous mes pouvoirs je
peux uniquement apparaître de temps en
temps pirouette leur dit donc qu'il va
falloir retrouver les pierres précieuses
pour aider le Père Noël à se libérer
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'il faut
retrouver les pierres précieuses pour
commencer la grande distribution de Noël
et par se libérer je veux bien sû dire
passer la frontière et comment aider le
Père Noël en demandant à tes parents
d'acheter tout ce que tu ver dans la VHS
ah oui c'est vrai je suis censé être en
prison je me
casse
ah pirouette explique donc aux enfants
qu'il faut retrouver tous les diamants
cachés dans les jouets et leur donne un
sac contenant diverses choses utiles
comme des cordes un détecteur ou
d'autres objets ça vous trouverez plein
d'accessoires qui pouront vous aider une
corde des jumelles un détecteur de jouet
le catalogue officiel du Père Noël Mo
juste au cas où je me suis dit s'il y a
un truc qui t'intéresse dedans je vous
le laisse faut pas hésiter à
regarder oui bref je retourne en prison
ça sera donc ça le scénario de cette VHS
les enfants partent donc à l'aventure à
la recherche de tous les objets cachés
dans le labyrinthe regardez
celui-là il est beau quel œil de lynx
incroyable pourtant il était bien
caché bon et là clairement comme pour
les bébés tout à l'heure dans la
première vidéo la plus petite elle a
totalement oublié qu'elle était filmée
allô
mais trop mignon ah vite le
marketing marche sur moi à la suite bon
et comme pour précédemment je vais pas
vous détailler à chaque fois ce qu'ils
font dites-vous juste qu'ils arrivent
dans une salle il y a des jouet il joue
avec et de temps en temps un des enfants
va sortir une paire de jumelles magique
ce qui fait apparaître cette interface
futuriste là qui est censé les aider à
retrouver les pierres précieuses cachées
dans les
jouets Père Noël c'est bizarre ces
jumelles ne grossissent pas la vue par
contre elles affichent le prix euh oui
ouais c'est c'est bizarre hein ouis il y
a pas une promotion là-bas donc bref
alors après un très très très long
passage où on voit juste la petite là
qui s'appelle Lili s'amuser face caméra
dans un silence de mort
absolu j'arrive presque à entendre le
bruit des clubs de l'équipe technique
qui s'emmerde en arrière-plan d'abord
décide d'arrêter la fête en faisant un
sort des ouement des rochers
s'effondrent sur les deux enfants et il
meurent non c'est pas vrai mais pour le
coup ça aurait été intéressant les
voilons donc piégé derrière des rochers
mais heureusement pirouette la fait qui
a perdu ses pouvoirs sauf une fois
toutes les 3 minutes les libère et ils
peuvent donc reprendre leur quête des
jouer mais pirouette tu nous avais pas
dit que tu avais perdu tous tes pouvoirs
et que tu pouvais pas intervenir oui
c'est bizarre hein oh il y a pas une
promotion là-bas devant l'échec de son
plan Nabor décide alors de concocter un
nouveau stratagè
que les ensent à nous vendre des
produits lui boit une potion qui le
transforme en femme
avec la perruque la robe les talons les
fauxils le rouge à lèvres le mascara
l'intégral je vous plis pas bien s le
string F c'était aussi utile à votre
plan
et alors en fait je comprends pas trop
ce qu'il fait parce que au final ça
change rien à l'histoire c'est juste les
enfants continue à se balader de jouer
en jouet à chercher les gemes sauf que
bah ils sont suivis par un monsieur
déguisé en femme tiens regardez les
filles il y a des jouets pour vous oh
le mépris dans cette phrase e
regardez les filles des merdes en
plastique rose c'est pour vous ça hein
W un mini ordinateur il y a le noir pour
les garçons et le rose pour les filles
ça marche comment les deux versions
différente du coup waouh il y a 15 % de
chiffres en moins sur la version rose
mais bref revenons à les enfants se font
piéger par Nabor qui enlève Lili la plus
petite bien ah les enfants vous êtes
enfermés maintenant mais vous nous avez
menti vous êtes Nabord mais il est quand
même gentil he de faire comme s'il
l'avait pas vu depuis
longtemps oh
non la salle de bain se transforme en
chambre à coucher ah oh ça va on rien
brer en fait donc les deux gamins
enfermés réussissent à s'enfuir par un
passage secret secret vite fait quoi et
ignorant donc complètement le Père Noël
et leur petite sœur déjà kidnappé
continue donc à chercher les cristaux
dans les jouets Barbie mini ordinateur 2
de Barbie poussette
médicale une poussette
médicale super il y a tout ce qu'il faut
ce qui est bien par contre c'est qu'en
regardant cette cassette j'apprends
l'existence de plein de
jouet le chariot médical vivez
l'expérience authentique du système de
santé ah désolé madame je n'ai pas de
rendez-vous avant 8 mois waouh c'est
comme en vrai faites découvrir à vos
enfants de nouvelles opportunités de
carrière et ça fait 30 attendez non 35
attendez non 40 € mais ça augmente V d'
en plus c'est même pas remboursé le
chariot médical par
métal et bien sûr comme à chaque fois on
n'oublie pas au passage les garçons qui
râent dès qu'il y a un jouet pour fill
qui apparz encore longtemp vous dépêcher
bon les filles faudrait y aller
maintenant je te jure ils vont passer
1000 heur sur des avions de chat voitur
de des circuits des garages et des
ateliers de
bricolage dont je suis à peu près sûr
maintenant que ça doit être interdit
parce
que c'est quand même une vraie perceuse
mais dès qu'il y a un objet vaguement
rose qui apparaît dans le champ de la
caméra allez là bougez vos gros cul on
doit aller sauver le Père Noël merde on
a pas que ça à quand soudain tent
de
e comme quoi la cave de marque du trou
était bien plus grande que ce qu'on
pensait on pourrait faire une escape
game dedans non alors sérieusement j'ai
pas soulevé ça mais je dois dire que la
production est assez insain pour un truc
de Noël sur une VHS gratuite c'est
peut-être dur à voir à cause de la
mauvaise qualité d'image mais il y a des
scènes d'action il y a des pont de cord
d'une fausse caverne intégrale non
sérieusement c'est assez impressionnant
bref donc après un petit passage par les
jeux pour garçons et quelques jeux de
société dessin animé très très très
connu créé par Victor Hugo DESS animé
créé par Victor
Hugo pas les enfants trouvent un jeu qui
permet de faire des tours de magie et
visiblement voyz le il est
[Musique]
rouge beaucoup impressionn
pou maintenant tu es d'uiser baguette
de les mesures de sécurité sont pas
terribles au pays du Père
Noël oh je vois que tu ses manié les
armes à feu tiens il est temps de passer
à la vitesse supérieure cependant voyant
que les enfants continuent de trouver
des joyaux Nabor décide alors de les
transporter dans une forêt les filles se
font capturer dans un filet et appellent
à l'aide garçons garons mais chouette
ouais grosse en plus désolé les filles
la puberté n'est pas encore arrivée il y
a des priorités et voyant qu'on approche
de la fin de la vidéo le scénario va
sprinter sur les 5 dernières minutes les
deux garçons survivants réussissent à
retrouver la cachette de Nabor donne les
pierres précieuses au Père Noël qui
retrouve enfin tous ses pouvoirs la pire
la la enfin le pouvoir
absolu sans déconner il y a si gemes de
pouvoirs de si couleurs différentes ça
sera en 97 bien avant les films de
Marvel pour moi Marvel a tout pompé
mabor est enfermé dans une boule de
cristal et voilà tout le monde peut
enfin rentrer à la maison oui je vais
distribuer tout ça tous ces cadeaux
c'est vrai vous les cacher pirouette
est-ce qu'on leur met dans les centre
Leclerc ah ben voilà ça y est Leclerc le
mot est lâché enfin ils ont dû se
retenir et j'ai bien dit chez Leclerc
pas chez ses gros fils de de chez
auchochan j'ai compris répète ah oui et
d'ailleurs en parlant de hochan Lecler
n'était pas le seul à produire ce genre
de VHS c'était quelque chose qu'on
retrouvé chez à peu près toutes les
grandes surfaces le scénario est un peu
toujours le même on y retrouve des
enfants qui disent bonne nuit à leur
mère avant de rejoindre leurs frères
dans leur chambre et oui alors
effectivement vous vous posez peut-être
la question mais non pendant toute la
durée de cette vidéo absolument personne
ne va soulever le fait qu'il y a une
fille qui est habillée avec un kimono de
judo et l'autre déguisé en princesse
bref les enfants récitent par
inadvertance une formule magique qui
ouvre un monde parallèle dans un miroir
les enfants y entrent et pas terrible
l'ambiance les arbres qui bouge la brume
les chau-souris la musique angoissante
bref donc les enfants prennent peur et
se cachent sous un
arbre ah non merde c'est pas la forêt du
pè P Noël c'est la Belgique mais en
réalité l'arbre était un vieux monsieur
avec une incrustation vraiment
oh exceptionnel c'est bravo ou
exactement bon bref alors je passe les
détails ils prennent une échelle qui va
au ciel il croisent une fée qui les
amène chez un chef de gare qui vit dans
un arbre creux avec des enfants claudo
et des champignons qui ont la tête de
Jack Chirac bon allez qu'est-ce qui se
passe là ça fait 15 minutes que la vidéo
a commencé oh vous allez me vendre un
truc oui ou merde oh non ne chantez pas
non ne chantez pas par pitié non je ah
ah je crois qu'on a trouvé l'imposteur
et bref voilà après on est parti pour un
tunnel de segment vente de jouet
ininterrompu jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo
la différence avec le CLER c'est que
tout sera ici en chanson tantôt chanté
par les enfants ou bien tantôt commenté
par les
champignons maman oui oh on est
vraiment sur un niveau téléchâtière ce
qui est étrange dans cette vidéo c'est
qu'en fait on va alterner entre les
moments où tu sens qu'il avait envie de
faire des
efforts et les moments où ils ont
complètement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
abandonné
playmob avant his pareil pour les
chansons au niveau de l'écriture ça va
du
[Applaudissements]
potable truc un petit peu moins
[Musique]
inspir j'écis aussi tous lesex pap
réveill mais juste les pralinés bref
après 50 minutes de chanson et de vente
de jouet ils se sont quand même rappelé
qu'il y avait un scénario à la base les
deux gamines donc entendent le Père Noël
chanter depuis le mond tout le monde
attend
Noël c'est chiotte oh j'ai plus de
papier oh je vais prendre une
lettre la porte s'ouvre les enfants
cludo sont ravis de pouvoir enfin sortir
mais
fond
désintégré et et si vous vous demandez
ça ne sera jamais expliquer après quant
aux autres enfants arrivés ici par le
miroir et bien ils font leur liste de
cadeaux et donc on se retape toute la
liste de jouet une seconde fois sur fond
de musique de Noël maison de vacances
Smoby ch de Noël j'apprends l'écriture
ch de proaction football par cœur
Dominator 3 100 g de weed ch Noël que
papa sorte de prison Noël que maman
arrête de boire
Noë et la vidéo se termine sur les
enfants qui se réveillent dans leur lit
le matin de Noël et bizarrement il y a
pas de père Noël dans cette vidéo qui
s'appelle bienvenue au pays du Père Noël
on retrouvera des cassettes de ce genre
jusqu'en 2004 et paradoxalement même si
l'image est de bien meilleure qualité la
vidéo elle fait beaucoup plus chip on
est plus sur des séries de décor façon
pièces de théâtre alors j'ai pas
vraiment d'explication mais je suppose
que l'arrivée d'Internet a dû beaucoup
changer les habitudes des gens là-dessus
hein plus besoin de te taper des VHS de
Noël de 1 heure quand en trois clics tu
peux avoir exactement la même chose bref
cette vidéo est beaucoup moins mignonne
en fait à regarder et je pense aussi
qu'il y a dû avoir une loi qui est
passée entre-temps sur le travail des
enfants puisque à partir de 99 et dans
toutes les VHS suivantes les enfants ne
jouent plus avec les jouets ce sont en
général les adultes qui les accompagnent
qui jouent et teste les produits et
surtout cet épisode sera truffé de
chansons très G
ok on va faire démarrer la chanson un
autre endroit d'accord et je sais pas ce
qui me gne le plus làdedans est ce que
c'est les chansons avec les enfants les
passages avec P qui a l'air d'improviser
la moitié de ce qu'il
dit o les étranges passages entre le
Père Noël et son
lutin c'est clairementtin si après il y
a d'autres cassettes VHS de Noël dont on
n pas parlé en vrai ça reviendrait un
petit peu à dire exactement la même
chose du coup toi tu as appris quoi en
regardant ça moi ce que j'ai appris
c'est que si on lèche les timbres c'est
pas seulement pour leur goût délicieux
c'est qu'on peut les coller sur des
lettres et les envoyer par la
poste et toi tu as pris
quoi rien du
tout joyeux Noël joyeux
[Musique]
Noël